George st. Pierre what's going on in so
we were just we were just talking before
you came in and and we were wondering
because you know it seems like the the
people last longer in the fight game
than I think you know it was ever
expected originally and I think that's
partly because that's such a young sport
you know I don't think anybody thought
that we'd be seeing a Chuck Liddell Tito
Ortiz fighting 2018 but boom there it is
it's also cuz you're not just getting
punched in the face like in box exactly
you know boxers have like you know you
have two options the body or the face at
least with mixed martial arts as a bunch
of [ __ ] you can do right I believe it's
because your life stuff mainly not only
be more because of your lifestyle
lifestyle and your training then your
actual fight which is more likely to go
out and do can have section part of it
but there's a big part of for example
you fight when you're a top fighter in
the world you fight maybe twice three
times a year so but you train almost
every day so the way you train will
define your longevity and career a lot
of I've seen a lot of guy they leave
their they have their best sparring in
the gym they leave their career in the
gym so you never saw the best out of
them because they they destroyed himself
in training yeah that's not smart
no a lot of guy they do that a lot of
guys is that just ego it's an ego it's
also a there knock that directed very
well you know and I've seen it many
times and young guy they go up they go
at me like basically try to rip my head
off and you know like there is a time
forever you can't train like this every
day
well they look at it like it that's the
main event if they're training with you
it's like yeah and they do something or
if they tap you it's a main event for
them yeah but they depend of your style
too if you have a style was Napoleon if
I make an analogy like more like a
arturo gets east alley you know like you
like come forward and like phonebook
fight and like and then take a punch to
give one this is this takes a toll on
your body that is what people like
watching to just two guys standing
really close just beating the [ __ ] I
agree but this is not that the the smart
way to fight if in terms of blonde
gbt health this is not the way to fight
it's adjustment chess match man
now will you pull a guy a young fighter
aside and be like what are you doing man
this isn't there's no longevity in this
you can't be fighting like this when
you're sparring this doesn't make any
sense
well you just let them learn their
lessons the way they're gonna learn them
by some are basically untouched
unteachable but some are something you
some listen you know that the bet a good
fighter will listen to you you know it
will adapt it will modify style I
believe I believe one of the main key to
become a one with the best fighter is
always to become the Nemesis of who you
fighting up against so to become to
become that you need to be able to
change your style if you can't change
your style you always that guy that come
forward to take a punch to to give one
right you you won't go far you will have
some interesting fight now you know in
only a few fight but sooner or later
your brain can take that you can't rely
on your chin to to win a fight I
certainly can't I don't have one for
your last fight your original training
or your first trader he stuff me do what
was his what was his plan for your
training camp oh God
iiiiii my trainer is a pretty hardcore
guy not always I've not always the the
smartest tactic he goes like it's been
for your that you've been out we don't
know if you really want this so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna fly one of my
friend from Russia
and you organize a a private fight you
and him alone in the cage I'm gonna be
the referee and now you'll really knows
if you want to do this is before the big
fight yeah like a month before like a
month before one of George's original
trainers who has a completely opposite
philosophy that's not sparring he's just
gonna have you fight like Apollo at the
end of part one of the greatest
voicemails ever heard of my life George
says to be the voicemail and he's like
it's his old trainer it's a first
trainer he's like George before you
fight Bisbing you have to decide if you
really want to fight again there's only
one way to find out I'm gonna fly in a
pretty named a particular Russian
fighter a killer I 185 pounds like
killer did he fly Minh he now this is
this is what is proposed I was fighting
to a few so imagine imagine the
consequences of did you know even yeah I
win the fight I can break my Tom lose
millions of dollar because I can't fight
for the old fight did you think that was
a bad suggestion by him that was
terrible terrible but he's the
completely insane you know he used to
make me when I first start my I'm at my
career at night before I was nineteen
years old he used to bring me in in the
gym to to he call out a training session
it's ok to tomorrow you're gonna join me
at this place at this address at this
time we're gonna train there so when I
show up for training a guy was waiting
for me there and I was like this is when
I was like 16 years old
and he goes like today you're trading is
gonna be you gonna be fighting that guy
however you're not allowed to use any
striking technique you're gonna have to
beat him with your grappling I'm like
what he's like this guy was basically
mainly like a boxer like like just
purely boxing yeah but much holder enemy
I was like wasn't 16 years old and the
guy was like it juiced out of it out of
his mind like steroid he was a boxer but
he goes he can do whatever he wants to
you but you you only can you only can
use your your grappling technique don't
hit him
because I'm gonna jump in and hit you if
you do and I was like are you kidding I
thought that's the way a person that
it's they learned the skills of not
getting hit and bring the fight to the
ground which which I'm very good at it
that's how I developed at my skill but
the consequences of it if I would have
mess up could have been terrible so you
really had a philosophy of Darwin is
unlikely to be a big star Michael
Jackson's dad's philosophy no you'll be
a star by the time I'm done you'll be a
star you'll transition and die from
propofol why did you take four years off
by the way why did you alright I think I
don't like to say it like like this but
now I'm more open about it I think I
when I was in depression a little bit I
am I had a lot of pressure
for too long a lot of criticizes and the
way of the weight of carrying all that I
got a lot of also with personal issues
plus the the carrying all that that that
weight of being champion defending the
belt that criticizes and everything it
took a toll on me I'm depressed about it
and none that is all that together I
don't really know how to explain I
couldn't sleep at night I had a lot of
it and sheets the anxiety problem I like
to say because people are like oh you
got you you were famous or and money is
what the point you you seek attention
and service like I really I I felt bad I
had like my heart was beating at night I
couldn't sleep I felt my heart beating
and my buddy it it was very weird
feeling and I loved a hang City crisis
and personal problem on top of that
things didn't go where my family and
stuff it man I needed to take some time
off I really did and and and and this is
a sport that need to keep going you
can't put the belt on hold and say okay
wait I'm gonna take a few more out and
then come back as I so I I release it
and I say you go and forget about them
were you afraid of losing I always been
afraid of losing I always been afraid of
getting hurt losing mainly using mainly
losing because I'm a very proud guy
which is one of my biggest strengths as
a fighter I think but it's also it could
be also a weaknesses because it drive
you crazy when they start referring to
you I mean does that because that's what
I was wondering does the pressure really
start to build when you start to build
this reputation as he's the best fighter
in the world he's the best to ever do
this he's the best of all time because
now every performance has to be the best
performance of Alzheimer and not only
that is a when you're a champion people
ask me sometimes say what is harder to
become champion or state champion state
Rypien is much harder the reason why you
don't don't see a lot of fighters stage
I've been very long because when you're
a champion you on top you're a target
every the old rust are they looking at
you and they tried to study your game
and try to investigate what is your
weaknesses how they can be your nemesis
how they can get out of your comfort
zone it's like the me too so it's only
right it's only your next opener it's
only your next opponent that is studying
you it's the whole roster right
you on the other end you have different
challenges as you win you have another
one you only have a few month maybe by
the time that fight get announced maybe
three month to study a guy but that guy
that used to be instead that you study
for a three month even studying you for
the last few years of course been on top
for a long time so you got a big
advantage over you and that's how it is
that's why it's so hard a champion when
your champion plus it's hard to motivate
yourself once you have something like
I'm trying to date a girl I'm great like
I'll have anything I'll take you out I'm
a loving person but like once I'm in a
relationship I'm shitty yes I already
have you there it's much harder to
motivate myself so it's kind of the same
thing I should have it you know the
hunger yes a satisfaction is the is the
death of an athlete like you need you
need to constantly be trying yourself
different motivation different goals I
saw when I came back after four years I
didn't want to come back and do the same
thing again I wanted to take on a title
in a new weight class every way class I
had three major criticizes I people used
to say to me I never went up a weight
class he fights he never finished his
fight you know because I was when I'm
winning a lot of decision guys that were
they knew it means they've been studying
studying me so much so they were very
hard to finish and also they were like
oh he's too tactically you need some
kind of drama into a fight so I wanted
to address these treating when I came
back that's why I I was very happy to do
it and it was a great motivation for me
so yes you know like if your satisfy as
a champion you're a chance of failure
much greater but you find you need to
reinvent yourself fine years of new
motivation to stay on top I'm kind of
surprised to hear you talk about adding
the dramatics to the fight like there is
a part of you that not only wants to win
but wants to make the fight entertaining
yes
and I guess that's the business side if
that's a business it's also as a that
the person you're fighting as a as a big
role to play to you know like Michael
Bisping my my dance partner was pretty
good at this you know it was a good
trash talk Loudmouth
that's a very nice guy but it was such a
such a conflict he's you know me and my
bad english i'm fred french accent him
and he's a bad dude he pointed out hi
sweets from united kingdom you know it
is a british accent as i oh my god is
what a clash i would that was it was fun
people want to see it when two guys are
just bashing each other it's kind of
more fun i'm already i'm not a good
trash talker that's not what I'm good at
I choose my battles very carefully I uh
if I would have go into a trash talking
war with him I would have lose pretty
much to everybody if English is not my
first language so I choose my battle
carefully you know I'm good at fighting
but if two guys are respectful me I try
to be authentic you know I'm not good at
trash huggens I don't do it and I don't
feel like I should do it but if the guys
if two guys are always nice to each
other is kind of boring to watch it's a
fighting right kind of drama to attract
the people that the fight are built on
drama but the the win our decide on
mundane things that you do every day
they're not people think the win the
winners pay the winning a speck of the
fire or this decide on on drum whether
or not they said build-up is decide on
drama will you not go ahead you I would
say what did you would you it what did
you for four years you said you were
different what did you do when you were
depressed to get out of it uh what what
I just needed to do time to step step
back take care of some problem and also
I had to breathe a little bit because
I'm I'm a little bit obsessive coppice
if when I have something in my might
think about it all the time when I drink
I think about it when I sleep I think I
wouldn't when I Drive my car I think
about it when I eat I constantly going
back in my head you know just give you
an idea as much as a guy will think
about sex I will think about my goal in
the same as much as this you know like
this is insane which which was which it
is maybe some something that make me
good at what I do but you become a
little bit obsessive
so at so it took some time for my side a
time to travel I'm a big fan of
Paleontology
had a time to go on site in different
places in the world people are very
surprised when I said I but I I like
dinosaurs things like that so I added
choice time to travel meet some
paleontologists microgame you can relate
to the obsession right
the whole OCD thing yeah the whole the
whole obsessing on something I can't but
I don't you believes you're able to
sleep I can't sleep what do you think
about as much as some people think about
sex myself I would say my sexual
failures but it's hard not to like it to
your minds just goes and it doesn't
stuff do you like like weird rituals you
do like I like anything's with numbers
or anything like that or like that are
there OCD ritualistic there's things
that is mostly visualization and and I
have this thing that I would never let
myself leave my my image we might
visualize visualization on on a bad note
on a negative note that's one of the key
point I tells young fighters or
performers or and then when I do
conferences it's very important
visualization is it's it's like a real
soul in your head so when you do your
your thing it's like not that for its is
it you've been practicing before this is
very important that's why you see some
guys they're very good and the gym but
when they go into the fight they mess up
because the the one of the best quality
of a champion a champion will be good
when it count will be able to pull the
trigger and when it can some guy they're
not good when they come when they come
the pressure crush them and everything
so one of the main key for this is be
able to visualize and this is a skill
that you learn as you as you do it and
then visualize is very important because
it every part of your brain and when you
fight you you you can you can enhance
how all that these part of your brain
that are reacting the same part of your
brain that you that will react when you
fight you will you will work on it while
you visualize as well so it's very
important to it's it's something that
you learn as you do it
it has to be done so if you visualize
something negative and shitty you make
sure you finish it on a positive yes
exactly and and sometime before a fight
I'm not gonna lie is some time before a
fight because I'm scare and I doubt
myself sometimes I see myself winning
but sometimes see myself losing as well
right see myself getting drop I see
myself getting summit or or getting beat
up and at night I can't finish like this
if I finish my visualization or I have a
flash in my head it's not good so I have
to think about it as if
think this this this thing happened what
I'm gonna do to get out of it okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna do this this is it then
I'm gonna go back to the upper end and
when the fight okay and then I can
finish my visualization and carry on
with my day
when you hear Georges st. Pierre talking
about his self-doubt and the fact that
like he struggled with it you realized
that no matter how good you get at
anything it's never going away never and
he always every fight get always bigger
and it's always more and more and more
and more stressful more pressure and of
course you don't want to go back and
like you want to come forward and do
more things and that's a good thing
your my positive visualization is after
sex that a woman does asking for money
ask you for money add multiple orgasm I
can't even sell it to myself you did
some interviews like several years ago
you did Rogaine you did Chael Sonnen and
you were talking about how there would
be periods of time that your memory
would go away like you'd go like two
three four hours would just kind of
disappear and you you theorized whether
it was a alien abduction or or or what
it was now do you think it was alien
abduction no have you found out what it
was this is the this this is because
people the people they say that to me
but I look at this one thing this this
actor for example when you lose memory
you could be like falling asleep then
you wait you know this this could be
slip around paralysis there was more
logical thing there was way more logical
reason for that anything so yeah of
course it the thing is that that what
freaked me out is I saw a movie at some
movie and documentary that people that
claim they got in abducted by it and and
and then they say they say they are the
same thing that happening to them that
imagine that would be that what I said
is I imagine that if I'm all wrong about
those theory and that's what happened
that would be crazy
you know why see that there's way more
logical explanation possibility you
don't know why it is but
what we don't know we don't know but I
mean I'd rather not think of that and
but you did see I was reading that you
and Rashad Evans at one point did see a
UFO is that true i we were we were we
were five people in the car and when I
saw that and if this is true and I
didn't say like that once again it's
people they misunderstand Clara clay
they say alien it doesn't mean if it's a
unintelligible it's an alien it's an
intent afire we don't know maybe there's
a there's probably an explanation to
that we can explain but at that time we
can explain you know I I read something
like most of an intent
unidentified flying object when they've
been studied there's an explanation for
it there's only a few a little
percentage of it that there is no
percentage that yes figure out yes but
that was pretty strange and the thing
that what would it look like to me look
that's I think that makes it interesting
yes the way I described it are different
than the way Russia described that way
that my Mike Van Arsdale described it
the way that ali abdel aziz described in
the way they another guy Ali Andrew
describe it
where were you guys were in New Mexico I
remember I was we were on the highway
and so kind of a light and the light
went like like it you know like it a
pure kind of I don't know if it was like
a flame but not that the color of a
flame like a simile so like a comet that
nature a meteor a meteor but it but it
was not like a meteor was like a he came
and just you know like a like a you saw
it and then it you stopped seeing then
you certain so it's like a corridor and
then this hip area which was strange and
I went it up and we were in the car and
I remember when it happened nobody says
nothing after that after I feel so good
when it happened is like what that was
that did anybody think like I like three
you guys before you guys think he that
was a UFO did one guy go now was a comp
was a one of you guys that was like no
it's just a rock coming through the
atmosphere or all of you thinking it was
something else
oh if it was a rock it was a very
strange rock I mean I mean maybe maybe
the angle maybe he don't know I don't
know what it was
okay it's it's something that yeah I
don't know I never seen anything like it
what am i it's hard to describe because
there is not really anything compared to
come that I can compare to what are we
thinking if we had to guess earth flat
or round now of course is round
okay I didn't know you guys there's a
reason why you cannot see Mount
Everest's from your from your living
room you know even if you have very
strong binocular because the heart dirt
goes you know and I mean yeah there's
view yeah and you know UFO guy or now
you believe in it
UFO I believe there is on and that the
aliens that if you listen to
astrophysicists guy like me show Kaku
and all these guy I want listen to him
the more the more the more we know now
we know there is a lot of planet that
are like they they're like hurt like
planet you know like the the perfect
distance between their star and and and
they have like you know the condition
that life could could flourish you know
there's so it makes it more and more
likely as we learn about the cosmos that
we might not be alone but there we have
no proof of that
I like Michio Kaku but his examples he
does he does kind of use childish
examples see dumb stuff down yes he does
a little bit it does but I think it's to
make people understand yeah he's a very
smart guy very well it's scary but if
he's if we speak with the same language
that astrophysicists speak a guy like me
for example to them to understand I'm
not educated and I'm sorry
you tried to make it simplify before
people understand but but he really does
like and I love but he's like you know
and and little candy drops do you find
yourself like especially when you have
time off do you find yourself falling
into those conspiracy theory wormholes
on the internet like I do it's hard not
to yeah it's hard it's yeah that's I
love to read about it I mean I think
like the moon they really went the mood
I think they went to the moon but the
footage actually I don't know if it's
really really comfortable for us and I
uh we don't know anything they might
have filmed it afterwards just to prove
that they weren't well some I've seen a
documentary like a lot of the things
been point out that the
could be wrong if it would really be on
the moon there's that I've I don't know
I'm not an expert in this you know but
you think Kubrick might have shot it
that's what they say I don't know I
really don't know IIF I'm not educated
enough um that's matter but it's
interesting you know what I mean I
they're fun right 9/11 Kennedy or you
know the assassination of Kennedy all
these thing you know it's like it's
interesting but I I not I don't know I
am thank you because that's a myth
actually mark I think that was actually
that one okay but it is fun to go down
this conspiracy even I don't agree the
constraint it's fun to read like to
watch where they go with it like [ __ ]
maybe the right like it does make you
when you're in the moment like when
you're watching their thing
you get soup they can make it super
compelling you usually have to find
something else completely different to
go oh there's doubt here too but when
you're locked into when you're reading
the thing or you're watching the
documentary and it's and it's that
conspiracy theorists evidence yeah it's
really easy to get locked into it that's
true then you go to a party and talk
about it everybody hates you Plaza we
are we have like three minutes left with
you what are you promoting because we
didn't even matter Tim Tam was fit for
us had a great idea a few years ago we
came out with a an apparel for for
recuperation 12 recuperation it's pretty
interesting I gotta let him know Jimmy I
understand you having problems with the
ladies a lot of problems yes I think
help erections will be irresistible what
does it do whoa wow it's like a
jackhammer
Wow can you can you put that in the anal
cavity better for Jim its advertising
external use only please what is it so
it looks like it's like a an electric
drill I'm gonna give to him another shot
yeah hook back massage oh my god it's
literally like a jackhammer
it obviously doesn't help with headaches
it's the wow it's the world's most
powerful handheld massager it's made for
athletes football players soccer players
MMA fighters whatnot it's the fastest
way for recovering your muscular
muscular recovery so after hard training
after hard sparring you put that on your
muscles and it helps loosen up the
joints and all that but gym you can use
it for other things possibly you know
I'm understanding you're having trouble
with some in certain areas yeah I
certainly know you could hold the power
you've always wanted you can just beat
your testicles up with it I mean I mean
I do like that but I still don't people
don't know right right let me try this
somewhere
Jim was up very late last night
masturbating that's a minute feel good I
felt my calves are sore I've been doing
the weight vest or knee see this is like
a tiny little jackhammer oh my goodness
put on your leg okay Wow and it's metal
yeah you can you can switch there they
have you can oh my god different areas
yeah that feels very good I start
sitting there I'm like I don't know what
this is but that's actually really
awesome yeah cool there you go but let
me let me do your wrist powerful machine
yeah what's that thing on the side
that's the battery or you plug it as the
motor that's the motor as external motor
motor sport so it's called timtam and is
there is this a battery the batteries on
the bottom this is amazing
the battery really it really is this is
the same technology of like a power
drill because that's a powerful yeah
yeah yeah it's similar amazing and this
is this is gonna take you to the next
level by as athlete will always look for
different more efficient ways to
recuperate right why that else is better
than them at actual and massage it
target that point that you want to work
on it goes deep deep tissue in inside
perfect
I like to use it on a woman to always
want a massage sighs like yeah right lay
down
drilled into her back and you can get a
Tim Tam dot tech is that right yes go
ahead that web how much do these run for
right another right now they're $1.99
the other thing about bringing them on
these what you do both of you because
you because you bring George with you
Shark Tank oh and I tell you why cuz you
come up with some [ __ ] right and you
go like invest this much money in this
and it's not a good deal for the Sharks
they'll say no so you don't have to give
up any of your company right but it's a
commercial hmm
everybody watches the shark tank your
celebrity George you go on Shark Tank
you go like I'm George snoop here this
is what I use for my muscles and look at
these muscles they say no you strangle
them exactly yeah
yeah so I expect to see you guys on
chart in the meantime timtam tech that's
really great every one of us and yeah
exactly yeah just shaking presents under
the tree and you just hear it really did
feel really great on the back my legs
feel more relaxed already
do i oh yeah awesome you're ready for
your first UFC fight I am that's that's
what it is it's been too much muscle
tension otherwise I would have been
doing MMA a long time ago and before we
let you go to of course Dana said that
he doesn't want you to fight could be
but what do you want to fight again uh
yeah I took that the thing is I'm at
this point at man I have a when I
trained when I trained I feel very
confident feel strong feel feel very
great I felt better than when I was 25
but at some time I heard a lot of BS
stuff and things is like I'm and I'm
like do I really want to go back into
that circle so I'm at this point I'm
think I'm gonna take the early days
think about it and see what's gonna
happen you might not want to worry with
politics of UFC you know exactly I
understand have a business to run but if
it's to go back and and run for another
like title reign because they have a
business can I go back fight for a title
then you fight for a title you have to
keep the belt defended and they had it
and I don't wanna make del dole division
on on the whole what did you think of
the Tino Chuck fight because that's I
mean people left that fight going on
i watch it but yeah they a teacher Chuck
Chuck will always be remembered as an
incredible fighter that he was once
where but now he's gone it's normal
every day there's something there's
something that there's an opponent that
nobody can beat it's time nobody can
beat time even burner up kids one of my
favorite boxer he did it until he almost
you think I'm out of the ring right yeah
he was like 49 he went 50 150 but you
can't knock that now yet to stop you
know what I mean you there's a point
that you can you just can't do it man in
and then it's normal that's the way life
goes you know what I mean
yeah I'm 37 you know like I feel great
you know what I mean it's only what age
you have I believe it's the window you
know I've started doing it when I was 19
years old
glad that my window was it's very long
right but if you don't start until
you're in your late 20s or something
yeah you don't want the sport to retire
you you want to retire from the sport
and you guys always one of my goal maybe
maybe the support retired truck official
you think I don't like to talk about
like the guy I I hope I like truck I I
hope you will not go back you know what
I mean you know I remember Chuck as the
dominant champion that he wants where
you know I don't want to remember Chuck
as the guy like oh man do you see he
came back and it was true it was not you
know what I mean watch Ali fight like
yeah Larry Holmes
you don't want that you don't want that
you want to go but go out on top and
that's how are you that's how we should
remember Chuck like though it's the best
thing Mike Tyson ever did it's just he
realized in that fight when he lost he's
like I'm done yeah he's like I can't do
this [ __ ] anymore yeah go do one-man
shows and whatnot
a lot of Tyson did point to his pony
goes like I know when I lose to a guy
like this I'm finished said that later